FREEDOM.
THEY SAY DeSANTIS WANTS TO ERASE
THEM FROM FLORIDA SCHOOLS AND
SOCIETY.
SARA?
>>> PREPARE NOW AND ANTICIPATE
THE WORST.
OFFICIALS IN GUAM ARE WARNING
RESIDENTS THEY WILL HAVE JUST
MINUTES TO EVACUATE AND RESPOND
AS TYPHOON MAWAR IS SLAMMING THE
ISLAND AS WE SPEAK.
EXPERTS BELIEVE IT'S THE WORST
STORM TO HIT GUAM IN DECADES.
THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE IS
WARNING OF TORRENTIAL RAINS THAT
MAY RESULT IN LANDSLIDES AND
FLASH FLOODING ON THE ISLAND AS
WELL AS CATASTROPHIC WIND AND
LIFE-THREATENING STORM SURGE.
THE ISLAND IS HOME TO ABOUT
150,000 PEOPLE AND SEVERAL U.S.
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS.
CNN METEOROLOGIST DEREK VAN DAM
IS IN THE WEATHER CENTER FOR US.
CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF WHERE
THIS STORM IS HEADED?
>> WELL, SHARE RATION THEY'RE
STILL VERY MUCH IN THE THICK OF
THE STORM.
WHEN THIS VIDEO WAS SHOT A
COUPLE HOURS AGO THEY WERE UNDER
WHAT IS CALLED AN EXTREME WIND
WARNING, THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE RESERVES THAT FOR ONLY
THE MOST EXTREME WIND CASES.
IT'S LIKE GETTING HIT WITH A
TORNADO FOR SEVERAL HOURS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WERE
EXPERIENCING, ESPECIALLY ACROSS
THE NORTHERN AND WESTERN
SECTIONS OF THE ISLAND OF GUAM.
HERE IS THE LATEST SATELLITE
IMAGERY AND WE'VE BEEN
ANNUALIZING THIS AND KEEPING A
CLOSE EYE ON IT BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT A DIRECT LANDFALL WAS
IMMINENT.
IT WENT THROUGH WHAT IS CALLED
AN EYEWALL REPLACEMENT SO
ACTUALLY CURVED THE IF STORM
JUST NORTH OF THE ISLAND AND
IT'S BASICALLY HUGGING THE
COASTLINE ON THE WESTERN
SHORELINE AND THAT HAS MAJOR
IMPLICATION ON WHO GETS THE
STORM SURGE, WHO GETS THE
HEAVIEST RAIN AND ALSO THE
STRONGEST WINDS.
140 MILE PER HOUR WINDS AT THE
MOMENT, NEAR THE CENTER OF THE
CIRCULATION, IT'S A SLOW MOVER
SO IT'S DUMPING A LOT OF RAIN,
BUT HERE IS THE IMPACTS ON THE
STORM SURGE, 4 TO 6 FEET.
IF YOU RECALL YESTERDAY WE HAD
UP TO 20 FEET HERE ALONG THE
EAST COAST.
THAT WAS WITH THE ANTICIPATED
LANDFALL FOR THAT SECTION, BUT
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
SO THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS BUT
NONETHELESS NEVER' STILL GETTING
WALLOPED BY HEAVY RAINFALL AND
FLASH FLOODING WARNINGS IN PLACE
OR FLOOD WARNING WITH SOME OF
THE RAIN GAUGES ALREADY PICKING
UP OVER A FOOT WITH ANOTHER 5 TO
10 INCHES OF ADDITIONAL